c'est quoi cette un jour ce sont les
toubous bac une chaîne de montagnes
totalement inexplorés en pleine forêt
amazonienne et personne n'a jamais été
là bas
non personne
pourquoi lire un jour au tango mag oui
mon cv
prends soin de toi
voilà
alors jeune homme étonnant comeback
comment comptez vous y allez quand
j'aurai réussi à quitter cayenne je
rejoindrai maripasoula de là je
remonterai la rivière voix qui jusqu'à
son lit ensuite les 42 km à pied en
forêt j'ai la rivière a mûri camopi pour
enfin arriver au pied du massif d'être
beaucoup mac est ce que vous espérez
trouver un idéal la vie pure tout se
paie dans la vie le bonheur c'est plus
cher j'ai la certitude de découvrir
quelque chose d'inconnu
d'extraordinaire
jacques lamarre six mois
mais deux un défi sans créera la fièvre
la chambre
l'un peut assécher dessus ça va j'ai
rien otomo koumac et je partirai pas
sans l'avoir fait
car tu l'as laissé partir c'est à toi de
le ramener fille
hélas